morning all a big day ahead for it is
now that we are going to learn
how the prime minister plans to get us
out of lockdown a lockdown
he is clearly hoping will be our last
boris johnson will reveal
a cautious roadmap to ease restrictions
to mps
in the commons this afternoon before
leading a news conference
in downing street at around about seven
o'clock this evening the nationwide
approach involves
at four tests this morning we can reveal
the first details of what we're
expecting
to hear from the prime minister later
sky news understands that on
march the 8th all schools primary and
secondary in england
will be open outdoor school sports and
activities will be allowed to begin
the same day the aim uh well it would be
to also allow people to meet one other
person in an outdoor public space
for example for a coffee or a picnic
from the same day
the 8th of march sky news understands
the next phase of reopening will be on
march the 29th when
outdoor gatherings of either six people
or two households
will be allowed including in private
gardens
on that day the aim is also to reopen
outdoor sporting facilities such as
tennis courts
and golf courses our political
correspondent joe pike
has this morning's first report
12 months into the crisis and today
boris johnson will announce the way out
so far we know all schools in england
will open on march the 8th
outdoor after school sports and
activities can restart
and you'll be able to sit outside with
one other person
for a coffee drink or picnic and from
the 29th of march the first monday of
the easter holidays
groups can meet outside to a maximum of
six people
or two households at the same time
outdoor sports facilities like golf
courses and tennis courts can reopen
and grassroots football can return we
know that the probability
of transmission outdoors in particular
with just two people meeting up
is much much lower than it is indoors so
that's not a terrible idea at all
the idea that schools are going to go
back all at once i think
is a little bit more of a risk because
um there's been the study by the london
school of hygiene and tropical medicine
which suggests that we aren't going to
be able to keep the reproduction number
below one
if all children go back to schools at
once this is just stage one
at each of the four stages four tests
must be met
including whether the government's
vaccine deployment program continues to
be rolled out successfully
it will also require evidence that
vaccines are effective
in reducing hospitalizations and deaths
among those who have been vaccinated
it will depend on infection rates not
risking insurgent hospitalizations
that will put unsustainable pressure on
the nhs
and finally that the assessment of risks
is not changed fundamentally
by new covid variants mps will vote on
the roadmap in the coming weeks
but some are already impatient everybody
accepted at christmas time because of
the new variant
we needed to go into lockdown again but
now that everybody's seen the success
thank goodness
of the vaccine and i pay huge tribute to
everybody involved the prime minister
kate
bingham the health service business
department
fantastic achievement to get this
vaccine to where it is today
but everybody's now i think hoping that
on the back of that with more
millions and millions and more people
being protected by the month
that we can actually now use that as a
platform to launch
getting more and more of the economy
open again the full road map will be
announced in the commons this afternoon
ahead of a downing street news
conference tonight lockdown is lifting
and hopefully for the last time joe pike
sky news westminster
[Applause]
joining us once again on the programme
the vaccines minister nadeem zahari mr
zowie always good to have you on and
as always a very busy day very busy week
for you and the rest of the government
clearly everyone is very keen to
discover how and
when we might be exiting lockdown and at
the core of all of that are the
the four tests that the prime minister
is deploying run us through those
good morning everyone yes of course so
it will be
first of all the vaccine program
continuing at
pace so we will offer the vaccine to
the over 50s by the middle of april and
all of the adult population
by the end of july the second
is that the vaccines are working and
that we're seeing
a reduction in infection hospitalization
of course death
the third of which is that infection
rates
are not rising because of the different
uh parts of the opening up of the
economy to a level which would uh
overwhelm the nhs and of course in terms
of hospitalization
and the fourth is variance i.e that we
are
managing to keep uh variants under
control
and that we're not seeing what we saw
sadly
uh just before christmas which is the
new variant becoming more infectious and
the dominant variant in the country and
leading to the
large-scale hospitalization that we saw
in uh december january
and of course even now so they are the
four tests it is
making sure that we proceed at each step
and are able to assess and then flex
accordingly but you'll hear more from
the prime minister both in the commons
when he presents
the roadmap but also tonight in the
press conference sure
and there will be parents the length and
breadth of england uh
looking enviously at the date of
of march the eighth for all the schools
to reopen however just in terms of the
four tests
that you've outlined the second of those
uh the evidence showing that vaccines
are reducing hospitalizations
and deaths in those vaccinated do we
have that evidence do we yet have that
information certainly not in the public
domain by my reading
so the prime minister will say more
about this but you will know that public
health england have been running a
couple of large-scale studies
uh the siren study which it tests the
front line
um health care staff who were in group
two
if you recall of the vaccination program
so very early on
and another study called the valdi which
has been testing
care home residents again they were
group one and of course the other
evidence but
uh the prime minister will be saying
more about that uh
suffice to say the evidence looks good
the oxford team
demonstrated their own evidence of
cutting transmission by
uh two-thirds and of course um we are
we wouldn't be in this place this
morning to be able to say that we're
going to reopen schools on the
8th of march and of course as the school
holidays begin on the 29th of march
we will look at the rule of six and two
families being
to um uh see each other outdoors
if we haven't yeah if we're not
confident that actually the vaccine
program is beginning to
really uh bear fruit sure
can we just be absolutely clear though
with with all schools reopening on
on march the 8th the expectation has to
be
that the number of infections will
increase
so that that as i say to you at the
beginning
all of that goes into the uh gradual
cautious reopening of schools
and then gradually reacting the rest of
the economy
as we vaccinate more people it is not a
coincidence
that the 8th of march is the date that
we have focused on because
if you take the mid-april date where we
will have
given at least one dose to all
over 50s offered that one dose
protection to all over 50s
if you go three weeks after the middle
of april that takes you to the first
week
of march now that phase one is
99 of mortality so it's no coincidence
that we are
uh opening schools after three weeks of
uh protecting the over 50s and that
phase one
and then we'll carry on i get that sorry
sorry to interrupt minister
the the reason is we have had for for a
few days now in fact and from yourself
and on the program last week that the
way out of this is to be incredibly
cautious
is to open things gradually i mean the
one aspect of the road map in which
it doesn't feel particularly gradual is
getting kids back into schools you look
at what wales you look at scotland
they're going in a phased
uh return to school so they can look at
the data see what happens in schools as
children go back
why are we not doing that because it
doesn't feel cautious it feels somewhat
in congress actually
to reopen all the schools on one day and
say that this is a cautious approach
well i would say to you it's actually
quite the opposite if you look at
where hospitalization and of course
death
has come from with this pandemic it is
from
that one to nine group all the way from
the over 80s
the those obviously um that are
clinically extremely vulnerable but then
also
the uh over 50. so we're waiting
until all of that group the over 50s
have got the protection i.e
three weeks after getting their first
dose before we
reopen schools and of course we do know
that uh
infection around amongst children is
very very low
and so this is a cautious
slow and deliberate reopening
as we continue of course to assess the
uh four tests that you and i have just
described to your viewers
i i understand that that certainly some
of the evidence that
suggests that transmissibility amongst
children is it
it's not as much of an issue as it is
amongst you know yourself or myself but
you only need to look at for example i
mean there are examples of this all
around the world the situation in
british columbia and canada at a moment
where the
the kent variant is right running havoc
through the school system there a number
of schools having to have temporary
closures
look we understand that the plan as
outlined by the government is that we
don't roll back
once something is relaxed that is the
way of it but but you have to say that
there could well be a big pause in this
roadmap
coming as we look at the data that
emerges from the school system
so hence why the the four tests if you
go back to your first question
um the dominant variant in the uk is the
one that you
refer to as the ken varian the vaccines
very high efficacy against the dominant
variant which is why we're confident
on the vaccine effectiveness
the vaccine rollout continues to be uh
you know going to plan we've in fact
brought it forward
more ambitious by mid april to offer the
vaccine to
over 50 year olds all over 50 year olds
but there is
a a you know a butt in there which is to
say
we have to make sure that infection
rates and hospitalization
also remain under control which is the
third test and the fourth test
back to your canadian example is that we
keep control
uh on variance and make sure that we
have that
ability to sequence which we have genome
sequence well largest one of the largest
in the world we account for about 50
percent of all
sequencing of covert muted mutations
um and of course surge testing and
isolation as we've been doing uh with
the
variants that we've discovered from
south africa for example and make sure
we keep that under review and control
so it is cautious we have to be careful
we want it to be sustainable as you
quite rightly described
and can we talk about the the second key
date in all of this march the 29th
which which you've already mentioned of
course the the suggestion is that might
be the point that we see
the end to stay at home indeed at the
end to stay local
plenty people up and down the country
myself included will be wondering
if that is the point at which those of
us who live
some distance from our families might be
able to go and see them
outside of course you're not allowed
indoors it is your reading of the the
relaxation that people can travel at a
distance
to see their family uh on march the 29th
if everything goes well quite right if
everything goes well
uh this is outdoor versus indoor we know
there is a plenty about to suggest that
outdoor the transmission is much
lower it is allowing two families
to be able to come together outdoors or
the rule
of six and it is a national um uh
rule rather than a regional or tiered
uh rule so i think the important thing
is to
wait to hear from the prime minister
this afternoon in parliament but also
this evening on the details sure but i i
will push a little bit on this and my
producer working with me this morning he
lives in leeds it might be possible for
him
to get home and come back in a day
whereas
for me to go home and see my family
would potentially involve an
overnight stay in scotland of the two
are either of those in your mind either
not possible not permitted or not
advisable
so as long as it's outdoors and it is
two families
or the rule of six then that is
what will be committed if the four tests
continue
uh to uh be delivered upon
then that will be the national um
lockdown of course scotland uh as you
mentioned
and uh northern ireland and wales will
be setting out their own
um road map towards
reopening their uh economies
as well so at the moment the focus is
very much
on you know steady as she goes outdoor
versus indoor priority being children in
schools
second priority is obviously allowing
two people on the eighth of march to
meet
outside for a coffee uh uh to to sort of
address some of the issues around
loneliness and of course
mental health as well and then the 29th
is two families or rule of six coming
together and outdoor sports
activities as well tennis
sorry minister can we then just just be
absolutely candid
even on the road map as i understand it
even in the best case scenario
pubs restaurants non-essential shops
hairdressers
beauty treatments and the like none of
that will be happening even in the best
case scenario
until the other side of easter well i
however much tempting it may be neil i
will not preempt my prime minister
before he
stands up uh in the chamber in the
dispatch box and
describes the road map to
parliamentarians and to the country and
of course
at the press conference tonight i think
uh it's important that
uh you know we we do this cautiously
steadily
based on the vaccination rollout which
has been you know i think
in many ways one of the great
achievements of
the coming together the nhs armed forces
the volunteers
the doctors nurses the private sector
that delivered
uh the vaccine both in terms of
scientists and manufacturers but also
they're delivering now for us in the
deployment
with the distribution so a lot of
hard work has gone in and we don't want
this hard-won
uh you know achievement
to be in some way jeopardized by uh
us you know emotionally feeling that
we've got to try and go faster we've got
to be
led later not the date very very quickly
because i know you have to go
can you offer a cast iron set in stone
guarantee that there will never be
another national lockdown
i think the important thing is to make
it sustainable you're absolutely right
now the prime minister if i look at my
own portfolio
has tasked us not only to deliver the
the largest vaccination program
in the history of the nhs and of this
country but also to look at
variant vaccines that may be needed
as an autumn booster if we need it
and of course a longer term future
proofing of the vaccination program so
i'm confident that if we do this
cautiously
and we do it based on the data the
evidence then it will be sustainable
and it should be the last time we ever
entered the severe level of lockdown
because of covert 19.
the demonstrate good to see you this
morning thanks for being with us
our political correspondent tom rayner
uh in the studio this morning good to
see tom
um what did you make of that actually i
wonder we just might start with the last
thing that we heard from from
the vaccines minister there this should
be the last national lockdown
but i suppose it it it's absolutely to
his credit that he said he would not go
so far as to promising that it would not
be
i think politicians have learned lots of
things over the pandemic but not making
themselves hostage of fortune is
certainly
uh one of those that we've seen coming
through i think what was notable
actually is that nadeem sahari clearly
doesn't want to steal the thunder from
the prime minister ahead of
his appearance in the commons and the
press conference later and that
indicates the government really do feel
that there is good news here
even though the watch word is cautioned
even though every statement is caveated
with having to meet the tests and
obligations i thought what really stood
out though neil
was when you asked about one of those
tests in particular this idea that the
vaccines are
showing efficacy particularly against
hospitalizations and deaths
you said that data is not yet in the
public domain
uh the teams are we said well look wait
for the prime minister but i thought
that was a pretty heavy hint
he said that the evidence looks good and
that we wouldn't be in this place this
morning
if we weren't confident the vaccine
program was really beginning to bear
fruit
tom any thanks indeed now some
pupils in scotland and wales will be
returning to the classroom this morning
in scotland at children in early years
education and the first three years of
primary will go back
while in wales children aged three to
seven
will start a phased return as well as
some students on college courses in
england well as we were just hearing the
prime minister expected to say that all
pupils in all years
will be able to return from march the
8th
our correspondent ivor bennett is at
steppen primary school in east london
forest
good to see you this morning either look
i suppose
from the part of the professional
educators yep they know
when they will be going back some
questioning if they know
how they will be going back if you see
what i mean
yeah indeed well look here at steven
primary school in east london uh the
head teacher and the teachers here they
are all absolutely delighted with this
news
that they'll be welcoming all their
children back uh come march the 8th they
say schools are much better places with
children in them of course they have had
the children of uh key workers and
vulnerable children of course during
lockdown but they haven't had all 700
people since before christmas and they
can't wait to have everyone
back so they're delighted parents too i
think will be
overjoyed with this news because it
means no more homeschooling and children
similarly they are desperate to get back
into the classroom and to see their
friends but there
are concerns about this on the safety
level from unions whilst they do of
course recognize how important it is to
get children back into the classroom as
soon as possible
they say it would be reckless to bring
all year groups back
at the same time and they would much
rather see a phased return of year
groups similar
to what's happening in scotland wales
and northern ireland
and so clearly still some uh safety
concerns around this but on the
on the whole here at least they are uh
broadly welcoming this move
ivor many thanks indeed we'll be
speaking to our uh throughout the show
um
uh also coming up at half past seven i'm
going to be joined by the shadow health
secretary john ashworth
ahead of those announcements on easing
locked and clinton discuss with him
we'll be taking a closer look at what
the roadmap means for hospitality and
leisure
with the chief executive of the british
beer and pub association
and the boss of pure gym both joining us
and then at quarter to nine we're joined
by an intensive care consultant
looking at the challenges still facing
frontline medical staff
but of course the big event of the day
uh from three o'clock we're going to
have
live coverage of boris johnson's
statement in the commons
that will of course be followed by the
downing street briefing at
seven o'clock this evening
and on top of all of that we're bringing
you a special program easing the
lockdown
annabotting in charge tonight from 9pm
uh let's take a look at a few of the
day's other news items now and the
foreign secretary dominic rabb is to
call on the military
to step aside in myanmar and release the
country's elected leader onsang su chi
in an address to the un human rights
council later
it follows demonstrations over the
weekend against the military coup
in which two protesters weren't
reportedly shot
is recommending the temporary grounding
of all its 777 aircraft powered by a
type of engine
well that suffered this catastrophic
failure the united airlines flight was
forced to make an emergency landing
after its right engine blew apart after
takeoff on saturday
rain raining debris as you can see over
denver no one was hurt in the incident
the airline as well as others in japan
is removing the aircraft from service
while an investigation is underway
right police and protesters have clashed
in barcelona for a sixth night
over the jailing of the rapper pablo
hassell bins stones and other objects
were hurled at officers guarding the
national police headquarters
before catalan police moved in with
vance to clear the streets
shops in barcelona's city center were
also targeted over the weekend by
vandals who broke windows
and looted
israel has closed all its mediterranean
beaches
following an offshore oil spill
authorities are still searching for the
source of the problem which led to tar
washing up along a hundred miles of
coastline
and devastating wildlife officials say
it's one of the most serious ecological
disasters in the country's history
health certificates will be required for
sausages and mints entering northern
ireland from great britain
under the terms of the brexit protocol
the temporary documents are due to be
scrapped from july
when the meats are set to be banned
altogether from entering the region
under strict eu laws on animal and plant
health
now thousands of cancer patients say the
pandemic is leaving them
out of pocket and struggling to pay for
the basics which is leading
to many suffering from depression and
anxiety that one charity is calling on
the government
to make the 20 pound per week increase
in universal credit
permanent to help those in most need
skies hernia sethi has the details
judith may be all smiles now but living
with stage four bile duct cancer
meant the mother of one faced huge
pressures
financially the burden was enormous the
extra money that i received
in benefits helped me to have and i'm
gonna say the luxury
even though i feel that it's a it's a
need
you know but um it allowed me the luxury
of not having to take public transport
which again
during covid um i can't even begin to
explain to you what it feels like when
you're fighting for your life
anyway and then to have the added burden
of the fact that even going to an
appointment
could actually infringe on your life
it's not just mobility that's a prime
concern
more than a hundred thousand people with
cancer in the uk
are struggling to pay for basic
essentials
ahead of the budget announcement on the
third of march
one leading charity wants urgent clarity
on universal credit commitments
if you're going through a cancer
diagnosis or treatment you shouldn't
have to worry about the financial costs
or paying your bills at the end of the
month
so that's why we are calling on the
government to continue the positive
measure they put in place last year to
increase universal credit by 20 pounds a
week for those on the lowest incomes
70 of people with cancer who are
struggling with living costs
have also had anxiety and depression as
a result of covert 19.
for judith her message is not to give up
cancer doesn't have to be a death
sentence you can live
with cancer you know and actually
with the support that's given to you
i wouldn't say that you can live the
same life as you led before
but you can still have a really good
quality of life
it's already an extremely tough battle
to face
but if financial implications are eased
it could be an
easier climb for some hinisha sethi sky
news
ethics time now to see how the weather
is
looking this monday morning isabel is at
the wall with the details isabel good to
see you it was
it was quite well it felt warm when i
stepped out the house this morning who
to thunk it
yeah i know it's mild and over the
weekend a few spots got close to 16
celsius 61 fahrenheit the average at
this time of year near around 10.
it does look as though the mild weather
will continue but some changes too
let's take a look
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
brighter for western areas today but
there will be some rain across central
parks that will gradually fizzle out as
it moves eastwards
and then this atlantic depression set to
whip up the winds and bring some heavier
rain particularly to the north and west
through tuesday and wednesday
this morning though with the rain
clearing from the borders of scotland
and continuing to ease away from wales
and western parts of england so
brightening up here
through the morning loving and sunny
across the north and west but the
the cloud obviously fairly extensive
across more central areas with some rain
at times
and that will gradually push its way
into east anglia perhaps the southeast
for a time as well this afternoon but
for many it's an improving picture as
that rain clears through
and then to start tonight it's fine a
little bit chilly in the east with some
patchy mist and low cloud
but the west turns increasingly windy
and wet and the problem is this rain
gets stuck across the north and west
through the course of tuesday and
wednesday
heavy rain running up through ireland up
into cumbria and scotland
and the met office and the scottish
environmental protection agency super
that looks the flooding
particularly concerned across southern
and central scotland where we could see
around about five inches of rain
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
isabelle many thanks indeed do stick
with us still to come on the program as
the pm
prepares to plot the way out of lockdown
we'll be joined by the shadow health
secretary
at john ashworth's up next
the nature of warfare is changing
an invisible enemy is on the rise in a
gray zone
between war and peace it's a global
battlefield
that thrives on deniability the weapons
of choice
include disinformation intimidation and
cyber attacks
everyone's a target into the gray zone
from sky news
warfare is changing and now we're all on
the front line
listen and subscribe wherever you get
your podcasts
welcome back uh time as always to have a
quick look at the latest
uk coronavirus figures uh yesterday well
we saw
9834 new confirmed cases of covid19
recorded in the most recent 24-hour
period
a further 215 people have died within 28
days of testing positive
that brings the uk total to 120
580. and more than 17 and a half million
first doses of the vaccine have now been
administered
well in the last half an hour i asked
the vaccines minister about
one of the government's four tests for
reopening the country
which is that vaccines are reducing
hospital admissions and
deaths i asked if we were already seeing
some evidence of this
suffice to say the evidence looks good
the oxford team
demonstrated their own evidence of
cutting transmission by
two-thirds and of course um you know we
are
um we wouldn't be in this place this
morning to be able to say that we're
gonna reopen schools on the
eighth of march and of course uh as the
school holidays begin on the 29th of
march
we will look at the rule of six and two
families being
to um uh see each other outdoors
if we haven't you know if we're not
confident that actually the vaccine
program is beginning to really
uh bear fruit
[Applause]
the child health secretary john ashworth
joins us uh on the program mr ashworth
good to see you
um you will have read as much as i'm
sure that i have from the papers you'll
have looked at the briefing
uh that there has already been from from
that which we understand the roadmap to
look like
what do you make of it well this has to
be the last lockdown
absolutely so it is the broad parameters
do sound reasonable we have to proceed
with caution
we have to be driven by the data
not specific dates we have to be
continually alert to the potential of
new variants
because we know this virus is now a it's
like a moving target we know it can
mutate and
we don't want to grow our own new
mutation that can evade
the vaccine we've got to lock in the
success of vaccination therefore by so
by continuing to suppress
the virus which is why we're saying
you've got to do more to break
transmission chains by paying people
decent financial support
to isolate themselves it's unacceptable
that 70
of applications for the 500 pound
payment are turned down
so we're calling on the government today
to fix that because it's a hole in our
defenses
so that if you're sick with the virus or
you're a contact
you can stay at home and to protect both
yourself
and to protect others it's not been that
much more than a week since the
government first started using the line
that you just used that we need to be
data driven not driven by by dates i
wonder whether it's kind of
not date or not dates but data plus
dates there are some significant dates
in fact uh included in the timetable in
the roadmap
as as we're expecting to be set out
later on and perhaps the most key
amongst it at that date
of the 8th of march for all schools in
england
to go back does none of that give you
pause
the idea that unlike scotland that
unlike wales we won't see a phase return
to the classroom but in essence
get them all back in sit back and see
what the data tells us three weeks after
well of course schools have been excuse
me schools have been open throughout
this um
throughout this crisis for the the
children of key workers um
i've always said that children may not
be the um face of this pandemic but risk
being amongst its biggest victims
it has to be in the interest of children
and society
that our children are back in learning
in the classroom
because we know children out of school
impacts their development it impacts
their mental health and their well-being
but we do have to be cautious we've got
to make sure that there are measures in
place to keep schools
safe like requirements around
ventilation and air filtration
guidance around mass squaring that
perhaps they set up nightingale
hospitals so
at the beginning ninety-year-old
classrooms so there are big mark the
other buildings and big and
units are put in place so the children
can be spread out because
what we don't want is to reopen schools
to all children
and then they have to have to close
again because infection rates
rise to what extent though is that
innovation that's been taking place in
the education sector being done by you
know the teachers the senior management
teams in these schools and how much of
it has been directed by central
government the complaint that i've heard
from a couple of teachers over the
weekend is that what look we know when
we're going back we just don't know how
we're going back i
mean you're absolutely right i mean this
is a time of absolute crisis for our
children and i think we've
probably got the poorest education
secretary in history
at the helm um he should be working with
schools he should be working with trade
unions he should be working with school
governors and teachers
to make sure that there is a proper plan
in place to keep the
schools open to keep them safe and to
help and support pupils catch up on the
learning
that they will inevitably have missed
now we know there's been online
zoom calls and home learning but it's
not the same as the children being in
the actual classroom
so we need this has to be a big national
priority now
to support our children and to give them
the resources
and to give them the investment that
they need so they can develop and they
can catch up
do you foresee a situation in which the
the the entire process
the return to normality or at least a
degrees of normality
the pause button could be hit pretty
quickly couldn't it if we start
to see levels of transmission in schools
which which other parts of the world
have seen in primary and secondary
schools
particularly with the kent variant yeah
well you've got
it's a trade-off which is why if we're
going to open we open
schools to all pupils which i believe we
should do
that will happen that will place upward
pressure on infection rates in
epidemiological terms
so you've got to make a trade-off for
society yes you've got to put in place
the mitigation measures in the schools
themselves
but it means you've got to keep other
bits of society closed
like pubs like hospitality i think in
the end this is about
your priority as a nation and my
priority
is putting our children first it's not
reopening the pubs
on saying that i recognize that those
businesses impacted will need help and
support
so let's let's expand the business rate
relief let's offer a va t
cut to hospitality and retail because
a lot of jobs and livelihoods are at
risk as well and they can't be left
behind either so let's offer financial
support to them
mr ashworth thanks for joining us once
again on the programme thank you
let's stick with schools uh many
teachers many parents are concerned
about the return of their children being
done safely sky's becky caution has been
visiting a school in
kent where a much-loved member of staff
died of covert 19.
mel michilski loved children and she'd
made a career
caring for kids the students she helped
now face returning to school without her
at just 51 and with no underlying health
conditions
mel died from covert 19. she was lovely
she lit up a room with her smile there
wasn't a day went past where she didn't
make
you laugh so much she was just
a lovely mum and a brilliant brilliant
mum when kovid struck
the school where mel worked 33 members
of staff were infected
her partner pete says school workers
must be vaccinated
if we need schools to return we most
certainly need to do something about it
because i think there will be more
more deaths at dover christchurch
academy
mel provided pastoral care for the
school's youngest students
there's a lot of concerned staff as you
would expect 900 students within this
building 150 staff members
and it's impossible to see how we can
actually
socially distance or make sure that
everyone stays
stay safe however on the other side of
things students need to be in school
today the prime minister will lay out
his road map for leaving lockdown
getting children back into the classroom
is his priority
and the 8th of march is the target he's
set but
is it safe to let kids come back then
experts predict that by restricting a
return to school to primary years and
only a small number of secondary school
students
we could keep the r number below one
meaning infection rates would still be
declining but if all children go back
the r number could go
above one and if other lockdown measures
are eased
transmission rates would be even higher
so this
is our gymnasium which we've turned into
a lateral flow testing facility
while we wait for all adults to be
vaccinated testing remains
key but for students will that
responsibility fall to schools
or parents here they are ready to test
children if needed
when they come back but their return
will be tainted
by the loss of their affectionately
nicknamed mrs m
becky cottrell sky news kent
well let's speak now to steve chalk head
of the oasis academies trust
which runs more than 50 schools across
england steve great to
have you on the program this morning um
you i imagine will know better than
better than most the negative impacts
that there have been in our young people
because of this prolonged period away
from
from face to face education what then do
you make
of all schools primary secondary all
years within them
all returning to an educational
environment on march the 8th
well the devil's in the detail isn't it
so what does
all schools return need i think that we
all know
all children learn best in the classroom
and we're
excited about the opportunity of
children coming back
we know it's essential but if you look
at
scotland and you look at wales what
they've adopted is a phased return or a
staggered return
and that's uh for all sorts of reasons
and
we would say the wise way forward is a
step-by-step
gradual return where you can monitor
how you're doing and you can monitor
whether you're going too fast
and slow down a bit or too slow and
speed up a bit
it seems to us it seems to me that
that's the
only sensible way forward because our
freedom has got to be won
it won't just arrive in our laps so i
think we need to
be cautious and move ahead
uh in that way it it isn't part of the
problem with that that you know
there will be kids who would go back in
under your idea there'd be kids who go
back in on
on march the 8th one presumes there
would then have to be a period of
perhaps a fortnight perhaps three weeks
as is happening
on the government's own road back before
more might be allowed in
i mean it could well be the case on a
phased
return that there are some children who
simply don't get back
to face-to-face learning this side of
the summer
well i think that another way you can do
it is
is to have rotors so you could uh divide
your whole school into cohort a
and cohort b and uh i'm if i'm in cohort
a across a two-week period i get exactly
the same education in school as cohort b
on the first week i come in on monday
wednesday
and friday and the second week i do
tuesday and thursday
and so that at the end of two weeks
every child is at the same in class
experience and given projects to take
home
i think the important principle that
most out of that
um really sad film that you've just
shown
the important principle that arises
is that if you can't social distance
actually you become a vector for
the transmission of this virus and
though it may not have
damaging impacts long term on the
children
it can do and it will do on some stuff
so one of the things we could do is
still perhaps the prime minister will
announce today
that all school staff are going to be
vaccinated
there are only a million school staff in
the country and we're vaccinating a
million people a day now
so you could vaccinate every staff
member of a school
in a 24-hour period which means that
everybody else would only have to wait
an
extra day to get their vaccination that
would keep staff safe
but you've got to create social distance
as well
for the children so that they don't
spread the virus back into the community
so faced or staggered returns a rota
system
and then uh one of your guests earlier
talked about
marquees in playgrounds and on school
playing fields
if you want good ventilation and if you
want cheap extra space
marquis in the warmer weather we're
gonna get is definitely the way forward
uh well steve i think i know what you're
going to be doing at around about half
past three when the prime minister gets
to his feet to
set all this up watching sky news i
suspect no steve chock
thanks for joining us in the program
this morning appreciate it
thank you still to come on the program
uh well his lockdown is lifted what
challenges
do the police fix i will join by the
national chair of the police federation
that's next
[Music]
toxic masculinity are these ideals that
we can tell ourselves are really
positive
for example uh never crying um but you
go through difficult situations in life
and you realize that actually those
ideals can be quite detrimental to your
mental health
i mean i was conditioned from a young
age that what makes a man is strength
and dominance and never crying and
getting on with things really quickly
i think growing up on a council estate
had a part to play in that and i think
culturally being a first generation brit
and having to really
fight every day my parents um to make a
way
in this country probably contributed as
well but when my dad
passed away in 2017 i tried my best to
be
you know this kind of macho man that
never cried
but it didn't really work for me and i
ended up
three months later kind of breaking down
in floods of tears on a beach somewhere
and after i had cried it was one of the
most freeing moments
i'd ever felt in my life and that's when
i started to explore
maybe what i was taught and conditioned
to believe made a man
wasn't truly accurate when i was 15
years old
one of my friends got murdered on the
council estate and
everything within me wanted to grieve
and
cry and show emotion but because i had
this picture that men can
only be strong i suppressed it and it
started to damage me on the inside for
the years to come so you're absolutely
right there's nothing wrong with being
strong
but i think when your body and your mind
is telling you that you need to
express emotion and you need to let it
out it's absolutely fine to do so
[Music]
ahead of the prime minister outlining
the route out of lockdown
the police federation is calling on the
government to avoid
mixed messages it comes as new research
suggests that only 10
of officers felt that powers previously
introduced
were clear we're joined now by john
actor national chair of the police
federation
of england and wales john good to see
you again um
talk to us a little bit if you can about
about the concerns that your members
are raising look we are coming out of
lockdown at some point and of course the
police
will have a role in enforcing whatever
the conditions
are on the basis of what you've read how
difficult is the job going to be
uh good morning now it's it's going to
be really difficult and i know it's
difficult for
so many people for so many different
reasons but speaking for my colleagues
so
i represent 130 000 police officers
across england and wales
and throughout this whole crisis there
have been ever-changing bits of
legislation i think we've had almost 70
bits of legislation change in that
period of time
and my colleagues have done the best
they can in terms of crisis we step up
we do the best we can
to protect each other and keep the
number of
deaths to as much of a minimum as we can
but it's been really hard
and we survey our members to make sure
that people like me
are speaking on their behalf and really
alarmingly
despite the best efforts of everybody
only
ten percent of officers one in ten of
those surveyed and it was many thousands
said that the legislation that was that
was brought in
during the crisis last year was clear
i'm bearing my nil they're the ones who
are having to enforce it and we've seen
examples where we might have got things
wrong because it's not easy
it's not easy to interpret what is the
legislation what is guidance
the public over the years certainly by
the end of the year
we're getting more frustrated there were
mixed messages
there that you know there was an
encouragement for people when we were
coming out of one lockdown to get out
and about and meet with their friends
but legislation was still in place in
some areas
so for today's announcement i plead with
the prime minister
just to give absolute clarity and
where we are frustrated is that this
will only apply to england
wales and scotland northern ireland all
of the nations will do things slightly
different
which in itself is really unhelpful
especially for us who represent officers
across england and wales
we've got a finite amount of time when
you and i have talked a number of times
over the
over the pandemic and both of us have
separately raised
the idea that policing happens in this
country with the consent of the public
what effect does a lack of clarity about
the rules
have on you know the the the average
member of the public's ability to
consent to being police
it it puts a strain on that relationship
and that is one of my biggest concerns
when we come out
well and get to whatever normal is going
to look like is what relationship do we
have
i think during this crisis the vast
majority of the public have completely
understood
that policing is in a difficult place
and they've supported
policing but they only support it if we
don't have to
please them and we've you know there are
good decent people who have fallen foul
of these rules
and we've had to enforce in some cases
in many cases
um i i think the the mixed messages have
been
deeply unhelpful for my colleagues who
are out there on the front line doing
their absolute best
the prime minister has a as a chance
today to try and set that record
straight
and give the clarity that my colleagues
need which in turn will help the public
john are you detecting any any
suggestion of course
they're currently working out the
protocols for phase two of the vaccine
rollout have you had any back channel
indication
that the police might well be in uh it
might well be prioritized more than
than they have been um
certainly in the early days we were in
discussions with the home office
national chiefs
council which is the chief officers of
policing from early december on this
and certainly the indications we were
getting was that police officers who are
up close and personal with people we
can't police
um with social distance uh unfortunately
and many colleagues been spat out and
coughed out so there is a
i believe a very strong rationale as to
why my colleagues should be prioritized
there was an indication that they would
be
and that was snatched away and i think
some elements of the public sector we've
heard earlier
about teachers do feel bitterly let down
by this and i know it's a contentious
issue but if
my colleagues are expected to police in
the way that they're expected to police
they need to have the full support of
government and that also includes
having access to the vaccines we have a
hundred and thirty thousand police
officers
across england and wales nationally
including police staff and special
constables who are just
as deserving of this vaccine probably a
couple of hundred thousand
police officers and police staff that
would take probably half a day in the
current climate to vaccinate
um john public sectors
so sorry john we are once again out of
time but i'm sure it won't be too long
before we speak again john actor from
the police federation thanks very much
indeed
uh time for us uh to have the weather
here's isabelle
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
brightening skies for the north and west
today quite pleasant actually with some
sunshine temperatures after a chilly
start getting up to about 12 in dublin
channel 11 for edinburgh now across
england and wells there is some rain
creeping its way gradually eastwards it
does cover central parts for a good part
of the day but then tending to tail off
by the time it gets into the southeast
not too bad tonight
but it's set to turn wet and windy
tomorrow
the weather sponsored by qatar airways